1219 anni fa in due territori molto
distanti tra di loro
baghdad in persia york in inghilterra
due persone con diverse cose in comune
non certo la medesima cultura uno arabo
all'altro occidentale hanno pressoché
contemporaneamente la medesima
intuizione una intuizione che avrebbe
ispirato i 1200 anni successivi una
intuizione che avrebbe condotto la loro
capacità creative assieme a noi quest
oggi a baghdad al cuore è un esperto di
sapere un curatore di biblioteche cerca
di comprendere in che modo offrire al
debordante complessità del mondo un
qualche criterio ordinatore cerca una
procedura che consenta di fronteggiare
la imprevedibilità del mondo
la insistente volontà del mondo di
sottrarsi alla nostra capacità
previsionale e inventa l'algoritmo si
chiama così in ragione del suo nome al
quaresma ma è uno dei tanti debiti che
noi abbiamo nei confronti della cultura
araba ingente all'algoritmo come
meccanismo in grado di garantire il
replicarsi di un effetto all'attivarsi
di una causa
niente di meglio per ottenere l'ordine
nel mondo un ordine di natura
omeostatica fermo immobile ripetibile
all'infinito
simile all'opera di dio possiamo
ispirarci a dio quando riusciamo a
ottenere nella complessità del mondo una
prevedibilità che fa di noi gli artefici
del nostro futuro a york un altro
bibliotecario
questa volta il bibliotecario di carlo
magno lavora a un progetto simile a
un'intuizione molto simile la
complessità del sapere fatto di molte
discipline differenti ha bisogno di un
ordine e divide alcuino di york tutte le
sapienze di cui quel mondo disponeva in
due grandi ambiti il trivium grammatica
e retoriche logica quelle che oggi si
chiamano soft skills dal quadrivium le
discipline del contare l'aritmetica
l'algebra la musica l'astronomia e su
questa separazione si intesterà a 200
anni dopo l'intero sistema universitario
europeo
esattamente come lo conosciamo noi oggi
le scienze umane da una parte il 3d e le
discipline scientifiche scienze esatte
dall'altra il quadrivio un'altra
formulazione che ci offre una garanzia
di ordine di staticità di omeostasi che
ci rende simili a dio e ci consente di
avere la meglio su questa insistita
volontà del mondo di sorprenderci
siamo circondati dagli algoritmi le
tecnologie li moltiplicano ci aiutano
gli algoritmi moltissime opportunità
automatizzano i processi ci danno
garanzie che alcoa ritmi non poteva
nemmeno immaginare ci affidiamo gli
algoritmi per ottenere diagnosi in campo
medico
le più precise possibili ci stiamo per
affidare agli algoritmi per far guidare
i nostri veicoli per portarci in giro
e ci affidiamo la categorizzazione del
sapere per far studiare i nostri figli
per dire loro scienze umane e scienze
esatte per sviluppare una facoltà ma il
mondo non è omeostatico il mondo è come
eretico l'ordine del mondo non si ripete
mai nello stesso modo il mondo non è
complicato fatto di procedure
burocraticamente ripetibili il mondo è
complesso e fatto di eventi che quando
sembrano sul punto di ripetersi non si
ripetono il mondo è un insieme di
cambiamenti imprevedibili che noi non
possiamo irretire per quanto ci
sforziamo di farlo in algoritmi in
procedure molte cose sono
automatizzabili e nelle organizzazioni
d'impresa tutto ciò che è passibile di
automazione sta per essere automatizzato
nelle università nei luoghi dove di
sapere viene prodotto e trasmesso tutto
ciò che è possibile preordinare viene
pre ordinato ma esistono tipologie di
esperienza e naturalmente esistono
infinite attività che eccedono questa
capacità di ordinamento la capacità di
ordinamento inventata 1200 anni fa
dall'algoritmo e dalla distinzione tra
trivio e quadrivio ha preso il nome di
uno dei nostri nemici principali la
burocrazia burro caratterizzano le
nostre decisioni
quando le affidiamo un algoritmo
burocratizza amo la trasmissione del
sapere quando mandiamo i nostri figli
all'interno di istituti scolastici che
trasmettono la scienza come fosse una
arte tipografica diceva come io
imprimere nella mente dei nostri ragazzi
la procedura corretta per ottenere un
sapere prevedibile
viceversa noi ci troviamo in equilibrio
costante
esattamente come un equilibrista tra
movimenti che sono imprese imprevisti
che non ci consentono di sapere quale
sarà la forma esatta del passo
successivo che stiamo per compiere
burocrazia è una parola composta da due
termini kratos potere in greco e burro
in francese bureau significa tavolo ma
anche norma legge procedura abbiamo
ragionevolmente burocratizzato una larga
quantità delle nostre attività ma la
burocrazia ci ha preso la mano ci
scontriamo tutti i giorni con gli
ostacoli che la burocrazia pone alla
nostra volontà di reimpossessarsi del
mondo produrre valore nelle
organizzazioni d'impresa durante il
predominio del settore manifatturiero ha
voluto dire per due secoli
burocratizzare le attività umane rendere
gli umani simili alle macchine
ricordiamo tutti charlie chaplin
all'opera alla catena di montaggio
burocrazia significa posso fidarmi di te
perché ti vedo perché ti so presente
abbiamo inventato una nuova parola per
il futuro dei nostri figli
si chiama zaino krazia vuole sottrarre
alla burocrazia il potere di prendere
decisioni al posto nostro
vuole fare riferimento alla nostra
necessità sempre più urgente di rivedere
il concetto di presenza non è più
bisogno
non c'è più necessità per produrre
valore di essere fisicamente presenti
nel proprio luogo di lavoro si può
essere presenti in contumacia si può
essere generatori di valore in assenza
di un controllore le macchine producono
un valore prevedibile e automatizzato
gli umani tutti noi produciamo valore
quanto più siamo in grado di sorprendere
i nostri interlocutori di fare qualcosa
che non era prevedibile certo rischioso
scivoloso ma l'esplorazione non è
della macchina l'esplorazione e
dell'umano la capacità di intravedere
soluzioni impreviste a problemi non
prima visti questo è l'imprevisto la
capacità di improvvisare al di fuori di
una burocratica procedura la capacità di
riconoscere in questa costitutiva
precarietà della nostra vita
il segno della nostra originalità il
segno della nostra bellezza il potere
dello zaino evoca la necessità di
restituire all'umano la sua
caratteristica distintiva il movimento
possediamo un cervello perché dobbiamo
muoverci è la ragione per cui le piante
di cervello sono prime non devono andare
da nessuna parte
grazie al nostro cervello noi possiamo
determinare il percorso possiamo
esplorare luoghi non prima esplorati e
possiamo trovare soluzioni che alle
macchine sono semplicemente per cruz e
dobbiamo decidere dobbiamo decidere se
nelle nostre imprese organizzare il
lavoro per facilitare il lavoro di
macchine burocratiche o se nelle nostre
imprese
vogliamo organizzare il lavoro per fare
in modo che questa sorprendente capacità
degli umani di stupirci i continuamente
venga messa a valore e dobbiamo
organizzare l'organizzazione del sapere
dobbiamo organizzare le nostre scuole
esattamente fronteggiando lo stesso
dilemma vogliamo fare dei nostri figli
macchine burocratiche solerti the l'anti
prevedibili o vogliamo offrire loro la
possibilità di distinguersi dalle
macchine per coltivare territori che
sono rischiosi possono generare
fallimenti devono generare squilibri
sono costantemente esposti alla
precarietà non danno garanzie di ordine
ma possono recuperare un ordine di
livello superiore l'ordine del flusso
l'ordine dello scorrimento non l'ordine
della stasi l'ordine del cambiamento
riconoscere un ordine nel cambiare
è la missione che egli zaino crati si
devono dare è questa la ragione per cui
abbiamo bisogno per ispirare una qualche
forma di futuro di riprendere questa
scintilla quella di baghdad è quella di
york riprendere quella scintilla che è
stata generativa fertile utile e
riappropriarcene e comprendere che le
risposte per la precarietà
imprevedibilità volatilità è intrinseca
ambiguità del futuro quelle risposte se
saranno burocratiche saranno vecchie le
risposte nuove sono di ordine 0 cratico
e la scelta è nelle nostre mani grazie
della vostra tc
[Applauso]